you
[Music]
and we were with a couple of other kids
today with interesting names right honey
boo boo and her sister pumpkin you're
right about that and they are talking
about mama June going from 460 pounds to
a size 4 what hey
our senior news editor Jennifer barrels
got the skinny from the girls and a
trainer who worked with Mama June chair
gosh its lead back in May of 2015 she
slowly started losing weight and her
stomach started looking grooves and I
was hanging from like what she's lost so
much weight and her arms and like her
chin so she got like her stomach removed
yeah and she got a baby yeah well well
the beautiful thing is well she got him
from 44 long to 36 36 up that's that new
person come on up
no that's okay it's not we do crunches
now in a new we tv7 per document too hot
you can see it all including June
working out with show trainer Kenya
crooks she'll reveal her new figure at
the end of the series for motivation her
ex sugar bears upcoming wedding you know
I'm not really well sure we're back I
want to show them how hot I can be is
she more confident yeah Brittany ocean
house you know pair underwear now like
you put the fans off with a bang pop
you